[Música]
[Aplausos]
a sesionar los 6 millones de personas
porque algunos pensaron que eran
distintos millón cien mil eran niños
ocho décadas después las cosas no es que
hayan mejorado mucho 800.000 personas se
matan cada año cada 40 segundos se muere
una de ellas es más desde que empezó
este evento ya se mataron 85
y hace algunas décadas un hombre que se
llamaba víctor frankl estuvo durante
casi cuatro años en cuatro campos de
concentración allí murió su esposa en
embarazo de su primer hijo murió su
padre murió su madre murieron amigos le
quitaron hasta el vello que cubría su
cuerpo porque había que desinfectar lo y
todas las mañanas se levantaban y el
capó de la ss armaba dos filas una
entrada a las cámaras de gas y la otra
entraba a las duchas tenía solamente 24
horas al día cada día así es que este
hombre dijo la única manera de
sobrevivir el propósito que yo tendré es
ayudarle a los demás a que tengan un
propósito pero pasó algo muy
impresionante cuando llegaron los
aliados y se produjo la liberación
algunas de las personas que
sobrevivieron a los campos de
concentración se mataron cuando fueron
liberados
y el tema tenía que ver con que como
decía nietzsche quien tiene un porqué
para vivir puede soportar casi cualquier
como y lo que los mantuvo vivos a muchos
era la familia que lo esperaba el
trabajo por realizar la misión por
completar la empresa que tenían y cuando
salieron y no había ni siquiera edificio
no había nada ahí se mataron
así es que el tema de sentido después de
varias décadas nos ha bajado unas luces
importantes porque la gente que percibe
sentido en su vida se recupera más
rápido de los postoperatorios viven más
años después de diagnóstico de
enfermedad terminal consume menos drogas
tiene menos depresión y ansiedad maneja
mejor los eventos traumáticos de la vida
trabaja con mayor fortaleza
el gigantesco lo que hace vivir con
propósito así es que me dio de eso pues
un día estaba inspirado y esos días
trascendentes y me levanté y fui a
hablar con jose es un hombre de campo
analfabeta que ayuda con algunos
jardines nuestros y le dije josé libardo
cuál es el sentido de su vida y el
hombre me miró con una cara rarísima y
me dijo yo no pienso es aprobado en el
frente pero como así como así que no
piensa eso es así conéctese a lo que
hace
ame a los que tiene cerca y deje de
preocuparse por bobadas
y yo disque haciendo un doctorado para
eso
entonces el sentido pasa por conexión
por eso vivir con propósito es el
antídoto para la desconexión y la
indiferencia y vivir con propósito pasa
por tres cosas primera conectar el
corazón y la razón a personas acciones
circunstancias y objetos valiosos eso
qué quiere decir que lo valioso nunca
nos es indiferente si tú dices que tu
familia te da sentido te hace palpitar
el corazón si tú dices que el fútbol te
da sentido te hace correr sangre por las
venas si tú dices que ese libro te da
sentido sientes algo por dentro conectas
el corazón a menos que tengas prohibida
la vulnerabilidad que seas de esos que
lloran así
porque les da vergüenza
cuando algo que es valioso para ti es
aniquilado destruido sientes rabia
cuando algo que es valioso para ti deja
de ser de forma natural
sientes tristeza cuando algo que es
valioso para ti está siendo amenazado o
corre peligro sientes miedo y cuando
algo que es valioso para ti está en todo
su esplendor sientes alegría a menos que
no te permitas sentir
entonces conectamos el corazón y tenemos
experiencia de valor y conectamos la
cabeza que nos dice si eso es bueno
corazón y cabeza a personas acciones
circunstancias y objetos valiosos porque
lo valioso hay que verlo puesto en algo
si no sea es invisible uno no ve la
justicia uno ve personas justas actos
justos una tuerca que casa justamente y
si estás conectado a eso tienes que
además diversificar el valor eso qué
quiere decir que si tienes una única
persona valiosa en tu vida por ejemplo
un hijo pobre niño no lo vas a dejar
crecer para que no se vaya y si lo único
valioso en tu vida es trabajar te toque
irte a vivir a la empresa porque sales
del trabajo y se te acaba la vida
múltiples personas valiosas con las que
nos conectamos múltiples acciones
valiosas que ejecutamos circunstancias
que celebramos en la vida y valorar las
cosas que tenemos ese es el primer
elemento segundo elemento del propósito
que eso que sea valioso realmente lo sea
y un punto para diferenciarlo es que lo
que es valioso en la vida te atrae no te
empuja lo valioso atrae los problemas
psicológicos empujan qué quiere decir
eso yo puedo tener mi ropa en colores en
degradé a dos dedos de distancia cada
prenda en mi armario porque palabras
como eficacia y eficiencia me excitan ha
sido un montón no opción uno porque los
valores estéticos el orden la armonía la
belleza me gusta opción 2 tengo un
trastorno obsesivo compulsivo
lo valioso atrae yo estoy con mi pareja
porque hay tantas cosas valiosas en ella
que me siento atraído o yo estoy con mi
pareja porque me empuja mi dependencia
afectiva se ve igual pero no es igual
alguien va corriendo por la calle y
decimos va persiguiendo lo que ama el de
al lado dice no va huyendo de lo que
teme hay cosas que parecen ser lo mismo
hay gente que sonríe todo el día pero se
quiere morir entonces el segundo
elemento del sentido es que eso que es
valioso me atrae
en últimas uno toma decisiones por lo
que es valioso en la vida si para ti lo
más importante lo intelectual y estás en
un centro comercial te sientes llamado a
entrar a una librería y si no puedes
entrar y te toca irte de allí dices no
me h no me encuentro me desconozco tengo
desazón cuando no acudes al llamado del
sentido tienes un desencuentro personal
número uno conectar el corazón y la
cabeza a personas acciones
circunstancias y objetos valiosos
sentir la atracción que te da dirección
número 3 eso que te atrae te da
dirección y le dices si me comprometo
voy para allá e ir para allá implica
arrojo porque tienes que ir en contravía
a veces de lo que se espera de lo que se
estila de lo que se acostumbra tienes
que incomodar te a veces puedes decir
que eres un cajero de banco pero también
podrías decir que eres un guardián de
los esfuerzos económicos y los sueños de
las personas
puedes decir que eres el portero del
edificio pero también puedes decir que
eres el responsable de las sonrisas de
quienes habitan en ese lugar puedes
decir que no hace sino pegar suelas de
zapatos pero también puedes decir que
eres un hacedor de estructuras
saludables para niños y según cómo lo
vivas así vives
entonces el tercer paso es que me
comprometo porque nos convertimos en
nuestras acciones no nos convertimos en
lo que pensamos por suerte porque si no
fuera lo que piensan algunos seríamos
asesinos en serie y otras cosas no somos
lo que hacemos y nos transformamos en
eso es la primera parte antídoto a la
desconexión segunda parte si ya conectas
corazón cabeza personas acciones
circunstancias objetos valiosos
experimentas la atracción que te da
dirección
y dice si yo voy para allá
cueste lo que cueste me levanto y voy
pues ahora te metes en un problema muy
grave y es que no puedes vivir con
propósito y ser indiferente porque el
sentido se contagia con la rapidez del
sinsentido
no es sino que tengas un amigo de esos
bien destruye teorías de esos que le
dices hombre mira el atardecer no el
cambio climático nos vamos a morir
pero mire los pajaritos no el deshielo
de los polos van a cambiar la dirección
se van a morir
somos un mero accidente en esta nave
llamada tierra soy nihilista del parche
nadaísta
y ser bueno pues voy por un poco de
cianuro le caigo a las tres porque qué
más
y si tú estás rodeado de gente así o si
tú eres uno de ellos lo contagias y
después de 15 minutos de hablar contigo
te da sueño y te quieres acostar a
dormir porque te roban la vida pero si
estás conectado despiertas la vibra y
las ganas de vivir
así es que si ustedes están hoy acá
por algo será y si ustedes escuchan hoy
cosas y se conectan va a ser imposible
que salgan igual de comentaron y saldrán
al mundo y en ese mundo que está afuera
para poder hacer algo que es clave que
lo hagan desde ahorita mirar a lado y
lado y al lado y lado hay personas no
importa el color no importa la religión
no importa la raza no importa la edad no
importa nada no hay que tener tanto
miedo descubrirás que todos somos
tripulantes ninguno es un polizón todos
somos tripulantes de la ciudad del país
del mundo
así es que sale afuera y es algo por lo
que puedas decir que esta vida merece
ser vivida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]